nearly 800 million light years away
something has been forming
scientists aren't exactly sure what it
is but
have dubbed it the black neutron star
and now it's headed for earth
what is this strange object
how would it change our planet
and what makes this new discovery
so dangerous this
is what if and here's what would happen
if a black
neutron star entered our solar system
what is a black neutron star exactly
well scientists aren't entirely sure
just yet but
they do have some theories
it all has to do with this mass gap
that's found in space
when a star dies two things can happen
if the star is more than five times the
mass of the sun
it becomes a black hole and if it's
under two and a half times the mass of
our sun
it becomes a neutron star
but what exactly happens when a star is
too small to become a black hole and
too big to become a neutron star
that's where our new space object comes
in
scientists from the laser interferometer
gravitational wave observatory
and the european virgo detector have
discovered an object
2.6 times the mass of our sun
[Music]
scientists think there's a chance this
object
is either the heaviest neutron star ever
or the smallest black hole
regardless of what it might be
scientists also discovered that
this mysterious space object merged with
a black hole
of 23 solar masses
this happened 800 million light years
away but
the gravitational waves it created were
detected here on earth
this could have created the most massive
black hole to ever exist but
let's say this object which is 2.6 times
the mass of our sun
didn't merge with a black hole instead
it came toward our solar system what
would happen then
well as the black neutron star came on
the scene
gravitational disturbances would disrupt
nearly every object within the solar
system
all planets comets asteroids and
everything else in space would be
thrown into chaos there's a good chance
that this would throw the earth
out of the habitable zone our planet
could end up wandering in the far
corners of space and with the planet
being
so far from the sun earth's temperature
would drop significantly
luckily this wouldn't happen right away
due to all the greenhouse gases in our
atmosphere
but soon enough earth would become a
frozen wasteland
and since we're not entirely sure what
this object
is the results could be very different
if the black neutron star were a kind of
magnetar
then we would experience intense solar
flares as well
a magnetar can release as much energy as
our sun is emitted in 100 000 years
in less than one second as
earth is completely frozen it would then
be quickly heated up as the black
neutron star
gets closer vaporizing nearly everything
on the planet
not to mention it would also cause tidal
heating
the strong gravitational pull coming
from this massive space object
would deform earth by heating our
planet's core
this would also give rise to massive
earthquakes and volcanic eruptions
and what if the black neutron star were
just
a really small black hole well the
results of it entering our solar system
wouldn't be any less destructive the
black hole
would slowly suck up everything in our
solar system
it would grow larger and larger making
its way toward earth
and once it gets to us its
enormous tidal force would pull earth
apart and there's nothing we could do to
stop it
there's also a chance that this black
neutron star
could be a regular neutron star that
then becomes a black hole
this would result in earth being quickly
destroyed by
all those consequences from before and
of course we'd all die
so yeah sorry we killed you a bunch in
this one but
it just goes to show that we definitely
wouldn't want these objects coming
anywhere near us but
what if instead of a black neutron star
entering our solar system just a
spoonful of neutron star
suddenly appeared on earth well
we'll leave that story for another
what if